all right we heard from rodney via text
message the other day when we were
drafting the best safety duos in the nfl
we don't have a ton of time but this is
your chance to say why you think we're
both idiots
smith and harris should be number two
mccourty and chung should be number one
because of the three super bowl rings
matthew and thornhill should not even be
on that because juan thornhill has not
had enough body of work um
quadray digs and jamal adams should be
up in there fitzpatrick and edmunds no
jakwisky tart and wart they should be
honorable mention but i'm going to tell
you jordan poyer yeah uh-oh here we go
this now devin mccourtney patrick
showing super bowl rings harrison smith
anthony harris um you know harrison
smith very consistent anthony harris led
the league in picks micah high and
jordan poyer really really good
consistent safeties justin simmons and
karine jackson two ballers yeah
audrey diggs all right just to be clear
i mentioned them as honorable mentions
just so you know just so you're not mad
at me and everything like that i i
messed up and i should have took micah
and jordan poyer though i definitely
messed that up
rodney apart from the fact that the
people in buffalo already hate you
because of what you did as a member of
the patriots to the bills they're gonna
love you because you put poyer and hyde
in there because they've been all over
chris and me over the past couple of
days because neither of us made them one
of the top three picks so you're you're
you're salvaging a relationship with the
bill's mafia right now but i don't care
about that but i know two things you
know
i never thought you would
i know you think
chris are both idiots for and leaving
them guys off the list i i i am you're
right i i should have put them you know
i don't know what it was i i got you
know what i just became a a prisoner of
the moment with the 49ers in my head and
the super bowl and i went ward and
jaquaski tart now listen i like your
mccourty chung thing i know what you're
saying but i don't agree with you as the
number one safety duo in football
where three super bowl rings says the
guy that has yeah
12 um touchdowns and 18 interceptions in
his career i know but this is the show
guys chung's not playing this year he's
opted out so it's kind of irrelevant at
this point
you're the man right great as always
rodney we'll talk to you again soon
we'll be back to wrap up this wednesday
edition of pft live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports